hello there fortnite chapter 4 season 2
Mega city is here this is the series
where we look at all the map changes
from the huge game-changing landmarks to
the tiny inconsequential details only
true nerds like you and I enjoy we have
quite a lot to get through today so if
you wouldn't mind doing the like thing
and maybe think about using Code adamaru
we can begin
we've got to visit the mega City first
The cyberpunk Inspired Urban Jungle is
the new Hot drop every single game the
detail here is mind-blowing neon soaked
streets with giant projections and movie
posters who knew the Ronin was a movie
star and this may be my favorite thing
ever the dragon on top of the main
skyscraper can do this
it breathes fire the detail of this
mechanical Beast is jaw dropping inside
that mouth is a detailed tongue with
teeth and on the outside that
exoskeleton with spine sections on its
back is a crazy high level of production
it seems too good to not be here for a
reason so here's my random day one claim
like usual I think that dragon is going
to come alive please epic games pretty
please around this new location is a
sushi bar with all new props and across
the street is an art gallery with many
of the Easter eggs we've seen over the
years from epic like the Unreal
Tournament image which was one of epic's
much older games here in the mega City
there is a vault which as always
requires a key card this time you'll
need to find a boss high card and his
henchman and by eliminating the big man
he will drop a key card as well as a few
top-notch weapons follow the card to the
Vault and everything inside is yours it
may not be as impressive as the ones
from last season are but when combined
with the loot you got from the boss the
odds are you're gonna win this game I
have faith in you the mega city is only
one part of this new biome standard
trees are now replaced with bamboo which
confirms that the bamboo we spotted in
game last season for one week was a
teaser for this update or maybe it was a
mistake there are new pagodas and other
buildings standing on multiple floors to
be explored with unnerving suits of
armor watching you one of these
buildings sits above Mega City but hold
up a minute a hot spring is now here and
yes you can eat yourself into the air
but if you look at this entire Rock
Mound this used to be a volcano and
should it ever become active again
there's a potential magma path leading
all the way to the neon streets below so
the mega City may not be in one piece
for very long and if you're wondering
what happened to the POI that was here
before faulty splits is no more the only
remnants I could find was this bowling
trophy a few pins a pair of bowling
shoes and a sign for the venue
everything else has gone
like usual I've scoured the island for
new details which could lead to
something in future updates and have a
look-see at this one on the south of the
island washed up on the beach is this
the mascot and signage from the old
restaurant in Chapter 2 and 3. fish
sticks has somehow found his way back
into our lives and could very well
become a sushi connoisseur down here
I'll let you know if any NPCs find this
and make something from it do you
remember the old days of hot watch well
look at this I know it doesn't seem like
much right now but right at the end of
the new biome is a wood yard and for
years these things have progressed and
constructed buildings over time and
right now look what they're doing in a
touch of Brilliance we can see that the
lines we use to get around are being
used to carry the logs themselves a
genius bit of Ingenuity and I'm really
hoping that one day I can say hot watch
again version 3.0
tingles one of the strangest things
introduced in today's fortnite update is
this over at the far right hand side of
the Island are these pillars not only
are they in a very specific order and
shape these bad boys cannot be harmed at
all they are indestructible usually in
fortnite if something like this cannot
be broken it has meaning theories needed
what you're thinking Midway through a
game it's possible for this to happen a
house floating in the sky those who've
been playing this game for far too long
like me will know this is the house from
chapter one it can emerge from thin air
and exist just floating happily in the
sky this building has so much history
first a solitary house was in the center
of loot Lake we thought nothing of it
and then suddenly it became bouncy we
called it Thanos Lake and then the
darkness took hold and sent it Skyward
it did a few laps of the island and
finally in a mighty explosion it was
removed from reality then for no reason
at all it dropped out of the sky and
into the new Waters of chapter three and
now we think we know why it looks like
this thing has been reality hopping for
a few years inside it's like the good
old days with one very big update a
vault this one doesn't need a key card
just a couple of keys and the loot is
all yours
[Music]
the new kinetic sword is a game changer
especially for movement but did you know
there are multiple places on the island
where you can find these dueling circles
each with two swords if you choose to
land here be prepared for an epic battle
like an old Samurai movie or just run
away you do you okay so what's the story
this season the rift gate we built with
stellen was decimated in the final days
of season one and that Rift in the sky
was only the beginning hundreds of Rifts
filled the air and built what we see
today in game the thing is it's not
everywhere like the trailer suggests
it's only the Japanese themed bit but if
you see other changes Elsewhere on the
map please give me a shout I'm sure I've
missed something the peace Syndicate
have been on the island for quite a
while and this season they've begun to
speak to us and it turns out that they
are in a battle with another Syndicate
typical Evie informs us that the peace
Syndicate have been watching us in our
battle against IO for months keeping
notes on all of us and in particular the
imagined order it seems though that all
her information is corrupted so that may
take all the season to get some answers
I'll be back later in the week to give a
more clear overview of the story and the
season but as an opener this is the
first time IO have been mentioned this
chapter I guess we wait on the shapeless
man oh and this was surprising the
Citadel is still here and it's still
fine completely intact apart from the
riftgate of course right I'm gonna get
going I'll work on a story video and I
might do a myth Chasers episode if
anyone on my Discord is listening if you
have any Fortnight dumb science ideas
you'd like me to try with my Discord fam
please tell me in the comments below I'm
Adam you're awesome here's some Legends
who've used my code cheers